you've got
people working class people who were
months ago heralded as heroes of the
pandemic for keeping the goods
on the shelves
these people are now being demonized and
being demonized so transparently if you
just simply do any of your own work you
can find out who these people are in
fact i'm sure you're going to
talk about it but uh
you know there's a couple of journalists
who are
walking around at random when what this
does is it allows you to find out the
truth of the convoy by
following somebody around i happened to
catch a bit of the stream this morning
where he ran into people on the other
side who were protesting the convoy he
didn't write it so this is uh viva fry
yeah v-i-v-a-f-r-e-i
um youtube channel um he's um i think
he's a lawyer um
out of uh out of quebec and he's been
going to the um to ottawa to the
protests and just you know doing live
streams and
i highly recommend his
his today just ended right before he
started actually just by coincidence um
but yeah he heard that there were going
to be counter protesters there today and
he sought them out he sought them out he
actively sought them out and most of
them refused to talk to him
and those who did
were using
you know pat rhetoric
and
accusations that aren't true claims
claims of violence claims
claims such as we have heard over and
over and over again but the people who
were actually walking around there both
who are or who are portraying it through
live streams and other um and um and and
we hear from many private people who
aren't out there you know publicizing
what they're seeing
they're seeing none of this and you know
are there excuse me are there
are provocateurs on the ground
occasionally very few maybe i but
they're not even seeing those well but
okay i want to go back and and deal with
the agent provocateur problem because
it seems to me
right let's say there are confederate
flags as bizarre as that is in canada
right or swastikas or whatever
right
it can't you cannot live in to the
extent that we understand that protest
is an important process right this is
written into the american constitutional
dna to the extent that we understand
that that process is important the idea
that all you have to do to shut it down
is transport into it something vile
capture an image where the vile thing is
present with the other thing and then
the point is well the other thing is no
longer valid because you wouldn't want
to be near a confederate flag wouldn't
would you essentially what you're doing
is you're handing power the ability to
shut down critique if you do that so we
can't do that i mean
not only that
um but
the
i mean hypocrisy is not anything close
to us a strong enough word for what is
going on here
compare i hope someone does this
formally i i did not spend the time to
compile the comparisons
of the footage
and the coverage
of the black lives matter protests that
here in portland nightly became riots
for months
the media coverage of this was that it
was
mostly peaceful
there was actual destruction of property
all the time including actual
i was going to say actual statues like
that matters this only matters because
one of the few things that has been said
that has any accuracy with regard to
pushback against what is happening in
ottawa is that there was desecration of
statues and as far as i've seen the
desecration of statues involves having
put flowers
on a statue i saw a sign a sign around a
statue um so um compare that to the
toppling of statues the beheading of
statues you know
fake fornication with the head of
statues during the protest protests of
the of 2020
what could possibly explain
the complete inversion of the truth in
both of these cases
in both of these cases
yeah i mean and i i agree i you know
i'm pretty good with language
i know there's supposed to be a term for
what this is the
it's not even the complete
fictionalization of what's taking place
it is the exact inverse of what is
taking place exactly in in both of these
cases we're like 18 months later and
it's the exact opposite what is
happening on the ground is the exact
opposite of what is being portrayed in
the media and some number of people are
nodding along going okay
i guess it's true because i saw it on
the screen well you know because the
person who i've come to trust because i
see them on my screen all the time is
saying it to me therefore it must be
true
so um i had a very good discussion with
uh one of my patreon groups this morning
and this this is functioning as a
reality check in sort of the way the
dark horse is functioning for a reality
check for many people this group of
folks lives all over the world actually
and you know we get to check in with
what you're seeing what i'm seeing and
you know i actually was a little bit
thrown this morning by the fact that
what you and i are seeing about this
convoy is not necessarily even what
people who agree with us on the
substance of covid are seeing so sure
how is that the case but
um
the uh
the point i want to bring out of that
conversation is the question of what
role
a suspension of disbelief is playing in
what's happening and how much of this
effectively requires
the
the viewer
to
willingly accept the fiction in order
not to
confront the reality and
i'm seeing evidence of this um
all over the place really so i don't
know what to do about it but
the fictionalization that is taking
place is and i almost never use this
word but
it's evil right this is this is our
civilization attacking itself by
blinding people to the actual facts of
their
their existence
um but part of what is going on is that
there are incentives driving people to
accept the fictions because if they
looked even just
slightly outside of the screen they
would understand that what they were
being sold was nonsense right that you
know this is anything but a violent
racist protest right yeah
um
so it's it's hard of course to know
what what people do and do not think
what people are and are not seeing and i
had i had wanted to go right into dance
later but i think actually given where
we've been here
um talking a little bit about um
what the mainstream media specifically
has has said and done and and what we're
actually um seeing on the ground so um
don't show my screen here zach but
here's
um
here's
this is just out of a little country
newspaper in
ontario uh from
um a city councillor
and it's exactly in keeping with um
what is in the larger outlets
the sad humor of it all a relatively
small percentage of people who have
concerns about vaccines are being used
by well-organized white supremacists who
want to break up the country probably
funded by big oil money although we
don't know because so many donations are
anonymous and who would happily take
away the freedom of the vast majority
who want to go to work visit family go
to school and go out for dinner and a
show without increased infection risk
this is fundamentally an issue of how we
keep our community safe it is not about
freedom for the few to engage in
anti-social behavior but the freedom for
most people to go about their regular
lives without undue fear we make these
decisions every day when we create laws
we have used vaccine mandate
successfully for many decades as one way
to keep society safe
actually it's not humorous white
supremacists see the kkk cross and many
depictions praising the trump convoy are
hijacking the vaccine debate for
profoundly self-interested reasons it is
destructive to the country and people's
rights to safety i'm gonna leave the
guy's name off of that because i don't
need to
to start a pile on but there's so much
wrong
with that and this is an elected an
elected official um
well it's one of two things there's
really it has to be one of two things
okay that is either
a window into somebody's utterly
profound delusion yeah or it is
gaslighting
right it is it is attempting to convince
you of the inverse of reality such that
your own view of reality
will look insane yeah
um
the idea that the people
out in like
whatever it was like negative six
degrees weather today and throughout the
week are out there
trying to take away the freedom
of others oh the selfishness of those
people
cheering on working class truckers
probably funded by big oil money so by
the way this was written before gofundme
go fund me
um
took down
you know the the the gofundme for the
truckers for freedom um
movement had already collected more than
10 million canadian dollars and uh
something around a million or so had
been dispersed and then um due to claims
that appear to be completely false um
and uh and their reference to standard
um you know the sort of the small print
that they can make mean whatever they
want to
decided not to disburse any more money
yesterday they were saying
that you had to actually go in and
request your money back or they would
distribute it
by some other to some other
organizations and today they are saying
that they're actually going to refund
the money to people without you having
to make their quest that's so big of
them
but the idea the you know
the idea that this is white supremacist
this is funded by big oil that this is
about people trying to tamp down other's
freedoms uh that this you know that
this white supremacist of the kkk or any
of this
just
go and look at any of these videos that
are out there and
i will read later from or actually maybe
maybe i should read now from and this is
all out of order from what i had in mind
um
here we are uh you can show my screen
zack uh this is
from a piece called a knight with the
untouchables
i'll just read the first and the last
paragraphs
and again i'll link to everything in the
show notes i live in downtown ottawa
right in the middle of the trucker
convoy protest they are literally camped
out below my bedroom window my new
neighbors moved in on friday and they
seemed determined to stay
i've read a lot about what my new
neighbors are supposedly like mostly
from reporters and columnists who white
from distant vantage points somewhere in
the media heartland of canada
apparently the people who inhabit the
patch of asphalt next to my bedroom are
white supremacists racists hate mongers
pseudo-trumpian grifters and even
kewanon style nutters i have a perfect
view down kent street the absolute
ground zero of the convoy in the morning
i see some protesters emerge from their
trucks to stretch their legs but mostly
throughout the day they remain in their
cabs honking their horns
at night i see small groups huddled in
quiet conversations in their newfound
companionship there is no honking at
night
but i haven't noticed not even once are
reporters from any of canada's news
agencies walking among the trucks to
find out who these people are so last
night i decided to do just that i
introduced myself to my new neighbors
this is not someone and it goes it he
then talks about the people he meets and
this is not someone who i think was
particularly favorable to or inspired by
this this movement he lives there and he
wanted to go meet them because it was
clear to him that what he was seeing on
his window without even having talked to
them was a mismatch for what he was
hearing on the news
and he tells his story and it's he tells
the story of the people he's met and
it's amazing and so i'm just gonna
finish the last paragraph
as i finally made my way back home after
talking to dozens of truckers into the
night i realized i met someone from
every province except prince edward
island they all have a deep love for
this country they believe in it they
believe in canadians these are the
people that canada relies on to build
its infrastructure deliver its goods and
fill the ranks of its military in times
of war the overwhelming concern they
have is that the vaccine mandates are
creating an untouchable class of
canadians
they didn't make high fluent arguments
from plato's republic lox treatises or
bagajos i don't know that
uh interpretation of westminster
parliamentary systems
instead they see their government
willing to push a class of people
outside the boundaries of society deny
them a livelihood and deny them full
membership in the most welcoming country
in the world
and they said enough
last night i learned my new neighbors
are not a monstrous faceless occupying
mob they are our moral conscience
reminding us with every blow of their
horns what we should have never
forgotten
we are not a country that makes an
untouchable class out of our citizens
so
i'm reminded of this i think i've talked
about this once before on a live stream
but i think it's worth revisiting
there's a moment in
the movie the truman show
uh truman is beginning to figure out
that the world is being constructed
around him uh for the purpose of
misleading him so that he will
you know
do for the cameras what is necessary for
the truman show to be successful
and as
he begins to
get wise to this there's a moment where
he takes his wife
an actress hired to play his wife but he
doesn't know it
um into the car
and he starts behaving erratically
and the point is the entire premise of
the truman show depends on the fact that
he is predictable enough that they can
construct reality ahead of him before he
gets there and so he's driving around
this roundabout like a maniac because
the point is nobody knows what road he's
going to take out of there and so the
people who make the truman show happen
are freaking out because he's not doing
what he needs to do and the point is
that behavior
is necessary right you are being told
that these people are x you need to
behave unpredictably and go find out if
they are x and if they're not what does
that tell you about the truman show
you're living in yeah right
that that's the place we are and so this
is this is really the question is
if people are suspending their own
disbelief and buying this [ __ ]
all they need to do
is just flip that one bit
right you don't need to revamp your
whole way of viewing the world what you
need to do is flip that one bit and say
i am no longer going to do my part in
accepting this story i'm just going to
spot check it yeah i'm going to see
whether the story adds up and when you
find out that every place you spot check
it it breaks through it's it's it's rice
paper thin
right then the point is okay what would
have to be true for that to be right
right if every news channel is either
not reporting this story or reporting it
upside down what does that tell me about
what those news channels are what does
it tell me about what else is on them
right right that's what that's what we
have to do
[Music]